google l'informatique de pointe
los angeles ca c'était ma vie de 2010 à
avant ça j'avais fait une école
d'ingénieurs j'avais fait une thèse en
intelligence artificielle et j'avais
participé à la programmation d'un des
meilleurs programmes de jeu de go du
monde
c'est pour ça que google n'avait
embauché à los angeles
c'est pour ça qu'il m'avait demandé de
travailler sur la programmation de leur
intelligence artificielle de youtube
alors l'intelligence artificielle de
youtube qu'est ce qu'elle fait et
calcule les vidéos a recommandé sur la
droite de la vidéo courante et sur la
page d'accueil pourquoi c'est aussi
important parce que ça fait plus de 70%
des vidéos qui sont vus au total 700
millions d'heures de vues par jour sont
liées à cette intelligence artificielle
chaque heure de vue que vous passez sur
youtube youtube gagne à peu près 2
centimes pour vous c'est pas beaucoup
mais x 700 millions faites le calcul
logiquement notre but c'était de
maximiser le temps que les gens passent
sur youtube pour maximiser les revenus
publicitaires
est ce que ça pouvait avoir des effets
pervers
mais en fait nous nous posions même pas
la question
un jour j'étais dans un bus de lyon
jusqu'à paris à côté de moi mon voisin
passer son temps sur youtube il passait
de recommandations aux recommandations
donc du coup j'étais curieux qu'est-ce
qui peut l'intéresser autant à quel
point notre notre algorithme on faisait
un job fantastique
donc je regarde et là je tombe sur un
espèce de complot comme quoi il y allait
avoir deux milliards d'êtres humains qui
allait être
exterminés par sarkozy et d'autres
dirigeants mondiaux
alors je j'essaie de lier la
conversation de dix bons alors qu'est ce
qu'il veut nous qu'est ce qu'il veut
nous massacrer regarde un projet secret
il faut il faut absolument que tu
regardes sur youtube il ya toute la
vérité
mais les médias et les médias et non tu
regardes sur youtube tu verras est alors
j'essaye de regarder vidéos par vidéo
arguments par arguments de démonter
faire qu'un argument est bon ils sont
assez faciles à démonter et c'était pas
très compliqué mais au final après deux
trois vidéos sur lesquelles on a discuté
il me raconte oui mais toute façon il y
en a tellement des vidéos comme ça c'est
que c'est forcément vrai et là je me
rends compte que ce qu'il avait
convaincu ce n'était pas une vidéo
c'était la répétition et cette
répétition d'où elle venait
elle venait de l'algorithme que j'avais
aidé à programmer donc au final
l'algorithme que j'avais aidé à
programmer avait appris à mentir aux
gens
alors je me suis dit est ce que c'est
vrai pour tout le monde
du coup j'ai fait un robot qui allait
sur youtube qui suivait les
recommandations pour essayer de voir ce
qu est ce que les gens arrivaient quand
il suivait les recommandations
j'ai appelé le site sur lequel j'ai mis
tout ça à hugo transparente ci.org sur
lequel vous pouvez l
là je me suis rendu compte de plein de
choses qu' il n'était pas le seul
il y avait des tonnes de gens qui se
faisait emmener comme ça par
l'algorithme dans des bus de théories du
complot et une fois qu'ils étaient dans
ces bulles de théories du complot il
restait alors c'était des théories du
complot sur la terre plate sur les
vaccins qui
créé et génère l'autisme il y en avait
des tonnes
il la seule constante parmi toutes ces
théories du complot c'est qu'elle
faisait passer énormément de temps au
genre et donc générer beaucoup de
revenus publicitaires pour youtube
au final youtube c'est un espèce de
monstre de frankenstein l'algorithme est
composé des données de millions
d'utilisateurs et parfois c'est très
humain parfois on voit toutes les
recommandations de vidéos de chats qui
en fait tout le monde aime mais parfois
l'algorithme recommande nos pires
travers et il les amplifie l'algorithme
n'est pas neutre il va amplifier les
types de contenus qui font le plus
d'argent pour youtube
alors nous avons aussi eu un problème de
vidéos pédophiles sur youtube il ya deux
ans à youtube air france est le roi des
rois le roi des rats a montré comment il
y avait un problème de vidéos pédophiles
qui était recommandé par millions aux
gens c'étaient des vidéos est la limite
de la pédophilie donc youtube pouvait
pas les supprimer mais quand même les
commentaires ont montré de manière très
claire
pourquoi elle était là youtube n'a
quasiment pas réagi
il a fallu attendre cette année avec
deux articles du new york times disney
et nestlé qui ont enlevé leur pub de
youtube pour que finalement youtube
réagissent par rapport aux théories du
complot youtube a aussi finalement réagi
cette année ça faisait trois ans que
j'en parlais et la youtube a dit en
début d'année qu'ils allaient recommande
arrêté de recommander massivement les
théories les plus armées foules les plus
toxiques
il y a deux semaines ils ont ils ont
fait une statistique
ils ont montré comment ces théories les
plus toxiques avaient été réduites de 70
%
donc au final j'ai eu plus d'impact à
l'extérieur de youtube qu'à l'intérieur
alors si vous vous dites moi je suis pas
vulnérable aux vidéos pédophiles je suis
pas vulnérable aux théories du complot
mais en fait quelle que soit votre
vulnérabilité
youtube va la trouver moi ma
vulnérabilité personnellement c'est les
vidéos d'avion je sais pas pourquoi
quand je regarde une vidéo d'avion je
suis scotché
je clique dessus et je peux regarder
pendant des heures je me réveille d'une
transe au bout d'une demi heure une
heure et je me dis mais qu'est ce que
j'ai fait est en fait mon cerveau un bug
qui me scotche sur les vidéos d'avion
beaucoup d'enfants sont scotchées sur
les vidéos de couleurs il y en a des
millions et des millions donc au final
quel que soit notre vulnérabilité
l'intelligence artificielle sera plus
forte que vous si votre priorité n'est
pas là même qu'elle
alors est ce que est ce que les
ingénieurs essayent d'exploiter nos
vulnérabilités non il des vous il
déploie juste leur intelligence
artificielle pour augmenter le temps de
vue c'est l'intelligence artificielle
elle même qui va trouver les faiblesses
françois chollet qui est un expert en
intelligence artificielle à google dit
la situation actuelle correspond à une
perte de temps maximal avec une
efficacité maximale une perte de
potentiel humain maximale avec une
efficacité maximale donc on est un peu
dans une situation aberrante
c'est aberrant de vouloir suivre une
intelligence artificielle dont la
priorité n'est pas votre priorité
donc qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir faire il
va falloir vous garantir à chaque fois
que vous utilisez une intelligence
artificielle que vous connaissiez quelle
est sa priorité
qu'est ce qu'elle fait si sa priorité
est aligné avec votre priorité
cette intelligence artificielle pourra
être votre meilleur ami si vous ne savez
pas sa priorité
ou qu'elle n'est pas aligné elle pourra
essayer d'exploiter vulnérabilités
quelles que soient vos deux
vulnérabilités l'intelligence
artificielle a trouvé la trouvera donc
là maintenant ce que je vais faire c'est
travailler pour développer des
intelligences artificielles qui soient
alignés avec vos priorités que la
priorité de l'intelligence artificielle
soit la même que la vôtre mais
[Applaudissements]